Speaker 1: Let's look at a couple of wacky things
that have come across my desk over the last couple
of days. I do want to play this clip that many
of you sent me from attorney Alan Dershowitz, who
still says that he is a liberal and that he votes
against Trump. But he increasingly has been a
defender of Trump from the perspective of I'm just
giving you the legal argument. Alan Dershowitz
says that if Trump were to be prosecuted,
it would violate the Bible. Now, do we care
about that? Well, that's a different question.
Speaker 2: You talk about how this is bigger
than Trump, about if you're able to do this to
political opponents and dissidents, it sets bad
precedent. It allows prosecutors to go above
and beyond, and it actually makes us less free.
Without a doubt, there was a South American
dictator who said, for my friends, everything
from my enemies, the law. You can use the law
to get anybody, as Justice Jackson said, or as
the KGB had said, Show me the man and I'll find
you the crime. This is the worst example in my 60
years of practicing criminal law, of targeting
somebody for prosecution and then rummaging
through the books, giving people immunity and
trying to concoct a crime that doesn't exist.
And if this is allowed to succeed, none of our
liberties is safe. Today, it's a Republican
who's a target. Tomorrow it's a Democrat.
Speaker 1: Let me just say a little bit
about this. They keep saying this, Nobody
is safe if Trump is indicted. What you
mean is nobody's above the law. Trump's
not being indicted. If he is indicted in
an absence of any evidence that he committed
wrongdoing. We have a situation where there
is evidence and the fact that he was the
president doesn't put him above the law.
That's a good thing, not a bad thing.
Speaker 2: And the day after tomorrow,
it's your Uncle Charlie or your nephew or your
niece. Right. There'd be no limits on what
prosecutors can do to their political enemies.
And they're going to do it to people who are
running against them for the next. And it's just.
Speaker 1: And by the way, I think it's important
to say we already see. Economically biased
prosecution where we know that there are
certain crimes for which poor people are much
more likely to be prosecuted than rich people.
We already have that. And the Trump thing
doesn't solve nor exacerbate that problem.
The Trump issue is a different one,
which is are presidents above the law.
Speaker 2: A violation, not only a violation of
American law and civil liberties, it's actually a
violation of the Bible. The Bible instructs judges
to things don't take bribes. That's obvious. But
the number one thing is don't recognize faces
and do exactly right. Yes. Do not favor anyone
in a court. Yes, that's exactly right. Yes.
Continue. Sorry. No, that's and that's why it
violates every core of American values.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, fortunately or
unfortunately, I guess if you like this argument,
the Bible is not controlling the law in this
instance, thankfully. Although if it were up to
Republicans, the Bible would actually be the law
of the land. And that's a horrifying reality.
Hypothetically, if there were a court that
would hear a so-called Bible violation, then the
Republican Party also wouldn't be able to exist
since they regularly violate the principles of
the Bible despite claiming allegiance to it. But
that's a different issue. Alan Dershowitz,
once a widely respected lawyer. Increasingly
a laughing stock. And it really is sad. I don't
say sarcastically. It's sad. It really is sad.